كبيره يعقدها السودانيون على المبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه والتي افضلت الى
اتفاقيه لوقف اطلاق النار بين الجيش
والدعم السريع لمده سبعه ايام تنتهي بعد
غد الاحد مع امكانيه تجديدها لكن التحدي
الاكبر يبقى ضمان التزام الطرفين بوقف
اطلاق النار خرقت الهدنه على فترات متقطعه
خلال الايام الماضيه لكن بشكل اقل حده
ووطئه من بقبي لذا تضمنت الاتفاقيه بندا
ينص على انشاء لجنه مراقبه وتنسيق وقف
لوقف اطلاق النار تتالف من ثلاثه ممثلين
لكل من الطرفين المتنازعين وثلاثه ممثلين
لكل من الرياض و واشنطن
اذا اللجنه لمراقبه وتنسيق وقف اطلاق
النار تضم ممثلين عن الطرفين الى جانب
ممثلين من الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه
توفر اللجنه منصه لاستقبال الشكاوى وحل
النزاعات المتعلقه بالدعاءات وقوع
انتهاكات على ان تقوم بالتحقق من وقوع
الانتهاكات كيف تعتمد اليه المراقبه على
التقاط صور جويه بعضها عبر بيانات الاقمار
الصناعيه وذلك الى جانب تحليل منشورات
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وتقارير ميدانيه
من اعضاء المجتمع المدني في السودان بحسب
قناه سي ان ان في حال تاكد خرق احد
الطرفين لبنود الهدنه يتم اختاره بذلك
وتحديده بشكل علني ومطالبته بمحاسبه من ثم
ومن ارتكب هذا الانتهاك خاصه في الجرائم
والتجاوزات
الجسيمه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات